Daniel Friedman: Hello, everyone.
It's June 15, 2023.
We are here in lecture two of Chris field'
's course, physics as Information
Processing.
So.
Thank you, Chris.
Looking forward to the lecture.
Chris Fields: Thank you, Daniel.
And, yes, welcome to this session.
How?
This section is titled why Quantum
Physics.
And if you will recall, from the first
session, we reviewed the history of
physics and some of the history of
mathematics and computer science from the
end of the 19th century through to the
beginning of the 21st century.
And discuss the slow development from
classical thermodynamics of quantum
information theory and specifically
characterizing quantum information theory
as a new kind of physics that describes
systems that are exchanging finite
amounts of discretely encoded information
across some intervening boundary.
And so we use this very conventional
graphical notation of two agents or
physical systems, alice and Bob, A and B,
that are exchanging energy and
information across some boundary.
And I always use a blue ellipse like this
to indicate the boundary that separates
Alice from Bob.
And this new approach to physics is
entirely topological.
It's not geometric.
So it doesn't assume a particular
background spacetime, so it doesn't
assume that Alice and Bob are spatially
separated.
And so this makes it a very different
kind of theory from classical information
theory in that the channel that separates
Alice from Bob, this boundary is a
boundary in state space.
It's not a boundary in some geometric
embedding space.
And in particular, it's not a boundary or
a channel that's embedded in a three
dimensional space that separates Alice
from Bob.
So that's what we talked about last time
and today what I want to discuss is how
quantum theory in particular makes this
idea of physics as a theory of
communication simple and obvious.
And quantum theory, of course, has a
terrible reputation of being abstruse and
mathematically incredibly complicated and
counterintuitive and difficult to
understand.
And this is one quotation among many from
leading physicists pointing out that
quantum mechanics is just difficult.
And as you probably know, there's an
entire philosophical industry of
interpretations of quantum theory that
try to make sense of its ontology.
What I don't want to do today is try to
introduce quantum mechanics.
We're not doing any of this.
Some of you will recognize this as the
table of contents, the first part of the
table of contents of the famous textbook
by Landau and Lifts.
How that?
If you've studied quantum theory in
undergraduate or graduate school, you've
probably dealt with a textbook structured
much like this one.
And you've probably been introduced to
quantum mechanics as it was traditionally
conceived as essentially a mechanical
theory, a theory of motion with wave
functions and particle representations
and on and on and on.
So we're not going to try to do that.
This what we're going to do instead is
take a completely information theoretic
approach, and we're going to characterize
information transfer in a quantum
theoretic way without any assumptions
about mechanics or spacetime or any of
that.
So instead of this, we're going to ask a
simple question.
By a simple question, I mean a question
with just a yes no answer or a binary
answer.
So let's use up or down as our example
question.
And to ask this question, we need three
things.
First, we need an action.
We need a way of asking it.
For example, making a sound or writing
something down.
Second, we need a thing that we can ask
the question of.
We need an environment or a friend or the
rest of the world or an experimental
apparatus or some system or other that we'
're going to act on to ask this question.
.
And the third thing that we need to ask
this question is a shared language.
And it's the shared language that's often
neglected in models based in physics.
And I think the importance of the shared
language became clear in classical
information theory.
And it's become clear again, of course,
in quantum information theory.
But this has only happened over the last
few decades.
So what I want to do today is to
construct in a step by step fashion a
formal representation of these three
things that we need to ask a simple
question.
And what we'll find is that that formal
representation is in fact quantum theory.
.
So it's quantum theory that provides us
with a formal representation of asking
these simple binary questions.
And of course, if you can ask a binary
question, you can ask any finite number
of binary questions.
So you can construct an Arbitrarily
complex finite decision tree that ends up
formulating an Arbitrarily complex but
still finite question.
So this really is a general model of
communicative interactions between agents.
.
So let's go about this and talk first
about the action of asking you a question.
.
And so the first thing I want you to do
is actually say out loud up or down,
actually ask a question and then note two
things about what just happened.
The first thing to note is that it took
some time to do that.
That action actually required a finite
amount of time, a couple of seconds, not
very long, but it's not zero.
It always takes time to ask a question.
And the second thing to note is that it
took energy to actually say up or down.
It requires a little bit of exertion to
ask a question.
So let's put those two together and
define a word.
We're going to define the word action to
mean some energy that's spent in some
time.
So asking a question is an action and it
qualifies as an action because it
requires spending some energy in some
finite amount of time.
And so we can write this as action equals
energy times time.
Or I'll sometimes use the abbreviation E
times T.
And action is always required when there'
's some interaction or two way action
between systems.
So whenever we talk about physical
interaction, we're always talking about
two systems doing something to each other
that requires both energy and time.
So let's define another concept.
A concept of a minimum action needed to
ask a question, and specifically a
question with a binary answer.
And we'll just pick a symbol to stand for
that minimum action.
And the symbol we'll use because it's
conventional is h.
And it turns out that this h is planck's
constant, the number that planck came up
with when he was trying to solve the
black body problem back in 1900 that we
talked about last time and recall, that
was the problem of characterizing, the
spectrum of radiation emitted by some
physical system.
That was hot.
How much energy comes out as a function
of temperature.
And if you assume that the spectrum of
energy coming out is continuous, you get
predictions that are wrong.
And Planck got predictions that were
correct by assuming that that spectrum
was discrete and that this h represented
the minimum amount of energy that could
be emitted in a particular time.
So it represented the minimum energy
times time or action.
So let's look at an example of that.
And here's an example that may be
familiar.
It's the example of your own visual
system.
So in the retinal, the cells of your
retinas, there are many, many molecules
that are rodoxins of one variety or other
that respond to different wavelengths of
visible light, and they have some
efficiency for capturing light.
And let's just assume that they're
optimally efficient, that they're as
efficient as they could possibly be.
And that means that they require the
minimum amount of energy to change shape,
which is what they do when they're
impacted by Light to capture the energy
and hence the information that's
available in the Light and the minimum
energy to do anything that records one
bit of information.
So yes or no?
Up or down is 0.7.
So log two of Boltzman's constant times
the temperature.
And again, we saw this last time.
This is from roughly 1875 and was then
built into classical information theory
by Shannon and then by Landauer in the
mid 20th century.
So what we're doing is assuming that
since rudopsin is optimally efficient,
all it requires is this amount of energy
to change shape.
And it's known experimentally, that
rhodopsin takes about 200 femtoseconds to
change shape.
So that's 200 times ten to the -15.
Seconds.
So it's a very very fast reaction,
chemical reaction.
So we can just calculate what the action
is and at 37 degrees centigrade so human
body temperature KT is about 4.3 times
ten to the -21 Joule and Joule is just a
standard unit of energy and so we can
multiply everything together.
KT times zero seven times.
This response time of 200 femtoseconds
multiplied together gives you an action
of about six times ten to the -34 joule
seconds.
And if you're familiar with quantum
mechanics, you'll instantly recognize
that number because it's very close to
the value of Planck's Constant, which is
6.6 times.
Ten to the -34.
Joule seconds.
So this says that Rhodopsin is very near
to optimal.
The best it would be able to do would be
Planck's constant.
That's the minimum action that can be
undertaken.
So Rodobson is clearly doing very well.
It can't be as efficient as we're
assuming it to be, but it's pretty
efficient.
So this number Planck's constant is and
this idea of a minimum action is not
something we just pulled out of the air.
It's something that one can observe.
When you're looking at what real
biological systems in particular do and
other physical systems do.
So let's think about the second component
of this project of asking a question.
And that's the thing to be asked.
And we want to ask a very simple question.
.
We want to have a theory of asking very
simple questions.
So let's define the simplest thing that
we can ask a binary question to.
And let's say this is the thing that we
can ask a binary question of using just
this minimum action h.
So we're going to ask for the minimal
thing that it's possible physically to
ask a question of.
And this thing needs a name, so let's
call it a qubit.
And that word is a contraction of Quantum
bit.
And we can draw it like this.
A little sphere with an arrow through it.
.
That's called a block sphere.
And we use a symbol.
Q.
And that notation with the bar and the
angle bracket is called a bra notation.
And it originates with Durac.
So it's a traditional way of writing
inner products, actually, in quantum
theory to indicate the state of Q.
So this thing called a qubit only
responds to binary questions.
So it clearly can have only two states.
The state that answers yes and the state
that answers no.
And conventionally.
We draw the arrow going up if the answer
is yes.
And the arrow going down if the answer is
no.
And so those are the two states that the
qubit can be in when it's answered a
question.
So now let's draw a picture for the act
of asking a question of q in the state.
Q.
And let's draw it like this.
This curvy arrow is the action of asking
the question and getting the answer back.
.
And we're asking it of this minimum
system, the qubit.
And let's call this entire act of h and
write h acting on Q by this expression HQ.
.
So again, we're developing the notation
of quantum theory, which all of you who
know the theory already will find
familiar.
So the third thing that we have to build
into this picture and into the theory is
the shared language.
So we have to know what we mean by up or
down if we're going to ask the question
up or down?
And we have to have some representation
of what it means for the qubit to
distinguish up or down.
So let's say that to us, up and down mean
this little diagram with an arrow that's
labeled up on one end and down on the
other end.
So we're defining up and down in a very
simple way as just opposites.
We don't know anything else about them
except that they're opposites.
So this is a stripped down one bit
question.
We could have called them one and minus
one.
We could have called them A and B.
We could have called them anything.
We're just indicating that up and down
are two opposing concepts.
And so this object that we've used to
make this definition of the relationship
between our two words up and down is
called a reference frame.
It's a physical object that encodes a
concept or a meaning.
And if you think about using language,
using English, for example, you can
understand me speaking in English because
your brain has the right sorts of neural
circuits to allow you to understand
English and produce English using your
hand in your mouth.
And those neural circuits are reference
frames in your brain for understanding
and producing English.
And they encode the relationships between
different words.
So you all know about Chat GPT.
You can think of all of the weights on
all of the ten to the 19th or however
many parameters there are in GPT four as
a reference frame that describes the
relationships between words and phrases
in English and many other languages.
So this idea of a reference frame is an
instance of Landauer's principle, which
is often summarized as saying that
information is physical.
What that means is that information
always has to have some encoding and that
encoding, that object can always be
thought of as a reference frame.
So let's put all this stuff together.
What we have now is a reference frame
that defines the difference between up
and down.
We have an action that we've labeled H,
and the action acts on this object, the
qubit, which is in some state.
And what we've drawn here now is an
experiment.
And you can think of the incoming part of
the arrow that goes from the reference
frame to the qubit as a preparation of
the qubit.
So you can think of it as I'm doing
something to the qubit to put it in a
particular state like up, because that's
the state I want it to be in.
And I can think of this returning part of
the arrow as a measurement of the state
that the qubit is actually in.
So if the qubit is actually in this state
with the arrow pointing up, then I'm
going to get back the answer up when I
act on the qubit to measure its state.
So now we can recognize this action, H as
the Hamiltonian operator in quantum
theory, which always takes some time,
which we represent by an interval DT, to
act on some state, and in particular this
binary state, Q.
So this whole picture depicts the action
of a very simple Hamiltonian operator.
And again, I want to emphasize that we've
just defined the qubit as the simplest
thing that we can ask a binary question
of.
So how does this H work?
We can use H to prepare this qubit in one
of two states, which we're going to label
one and minus one.
The state one corresponds to the up
direction, and the state minus one
corresponds to the down direction, and
doing this to Q.
So preparing Q in one of these two states
takes energy, and we know how much.
Boltzman told us back in 1875 that the
minimum energy to reduce the entropy of
the universe by one bit is log two of KT.
.
We saw that earlier when we were thinking
about Rhodobson.
So we can say that acting with H always
requires some number times KT, where that
number is bigger than the log of two.
Remember, the log of two is just in there
to get units of bits of binary questions,
as opposed to units of nats, which are
questions that have e answers, where E is
the exponential base, the natural
exponential base.
But we want to use units of bits, so we
have to always have this factor of log
two.
So this lets us write H in a particular
way.
We can take out this energetic term that
Boltzman tells us we have to include beta
times KT.
And what's left over is, in a sense, the
pure representation of the action,
stripping out the energy requirement.
And we're going to call that M, because M
is the standard symbol to use in quantum
theory for a measurement operator.
And M is now dimensionless.
H has units of energy, KT is an energy,
and M has no units at all.
So it's H without the energy.
So now we can ask, what is this operator
M that we've defined as the simplest
possible action on a qubit, but
abstracting away the amount of energy
that we have to use to act on the qubit.
Well, what M does is just encode a bit or
decode a bit.
So we can use this operator M to say, I
want Q to have the value one.
I want it to be up, so I can sort of
reach out with my operator M and grab Q
and turn it so that its arrow is pointing
up.
And that's the operation.
That's called preparation in physics.
It's what it means to prepare an
experimental apparatus.
For example, you actually grab hold of
the apparatus, and you twist some knobs
and flick some switches to prepare it to
be in some state.
And you can use M to measure a state that
isn't known.
So I can use M to grab a hold of Q and
look at it and determine whether it's in
state one or minus one.
And I can represent these as just a cycle
that starts with measuring and then
prepares, or that starts with preparing
and then measuring.
And if I represent it that way, what I
see is M having a value which is either
the value I want to encode or the value
that I have measured.
And Q and M acts on that value and Q to
produce a particular state of Q, to put Q
in a particular state, or to realize that
Q is in that state.
And so M is actually an identity acting
on some value and Q.
So it maps one in Q to one in Q, and it
maps minus one in Q to minus one in Q if
you do the whole cycle of preparation and
then measurement.
And that makes sense.
It's actually an axiom in some
formulations of quantum theory that if I
measure the state of some object, what I'
'm doing is also preparing it in that
state.
So if I immediately measure it again, I'
'll see the same value.
And that makes sense physically.
If I put my coffee cup on the table and
then I look for it, it's likely going to
be on the table unless something else
intervenes.
Well, what does this mean?
It means that we can do a little bit of
algebra.
It means that we can write this original
expression of acting on Q with our
Hamiltonian in this somewhat more
explicit form of using the energy beta KT
and our operator M on Q.
And what I get out of that is the energy
beta KT multiplied by Q.
So HQ equals EQ.
That's the Schrodinger equation.
So that's one of the central equations of
quantum theory.
What it says is that this operator, H, is
the total energy operator on a system.
Its eigenvalues are the total energies of
the system.
And we can now see where that energy is
coming from in this very, very simple,
stripped down kind of representation of
an action.
The energy is the thermodynamic energy
that has to be spent to determine one
binary outcome up or down.
Now, if you're familiar with quantum
mechanics, you will have seen
exponentiated operators like the next
line here of algebra.
This operator P, which is time dependent
and which is the exponential of H
multiplied by it over H bar, is called
the propagator.
It's the unitary operator in quantum
theory, the operator that conserves
probability or conserves information.
And so, using the representation of H as
beta KT, we can see that this operator P
is just E to the minus beta M.
If we recall the WIC rotation from the
first session, this strange equivalence
of it over H bar with one over KT that
wasn't discovered until 50 years after
the invention of quantum theory.
And it's still a very debated thing.
I mean, people worry about what this
equation really means.
But one thing that it means in this
setting where H has this particularly
simple form is that the propagator is now
just the exponential of a number
multiplied by this very simple strip down
operator that encodes a bit or decodes a
bit.
But we know something about the
exponential propagator just by looking at
its form.
If you're again familiar with these sorts
of exponential operators, you know that
they're wave equations.
And we can make sense of that using the
diagram up above.
What M is doing is just performing a
cycle.
It's just mapping one and Q back to
itself, or minus one and Q back to itself.
.
So we can think of M as just taking this
object and flipping it back around until
it gets itself again.
And that kind of cycle can always be
turned into a wave equation and e to the
I over H bar times.
HT is a canonical form of a wave equation,
, where the horizontal axis here on the
wave is time.
Or if you look at the little cycle that I'
've drawn as a circle with an arrow, it's
the time of the thing spinning around
like this, which is exactly the same
thing as a wave traveling through time.
So that tells us something very important.
.
It tells us that this equivalent
expression, e to the minus beta M, is
also a wave equation.
So it tells us that this operator M has
built into it some sense of time.
It's the sense of time of this prepare
measure cycle.
And that's implicit in m right.
We've used the WIC rotation to get rid of
what I'll end up calling the external
time t, the objective time T.
And we'll see in July where this internal
time comes from in terms of the WIC
rotation.
But we can say now that it's an agent
specific time.
It's an internal time reference frame
that's built into our idea of this system,
, Alice, that can act on the world, and
it represents the time that's required to
ask this question.
Ander Aguirre: Okay, can I ask a question at this
point?
Chris: Yes.
Ander: So on this slide with the operator
M, I'm curious.
How can the agent deploy in the operator
M tell the difference or break the
symmetry between preparation and
measurement?
Or are they just completely dual
pictures?
Chris: Yeah, they're completely dual.
So the agent never breaks the symmetry.
The agent can't actually distinguish the
act of preparing from the act of
measuring.
Every preparation is a measurement, and
every measurement is a preparation.
Ander: Right.
Chris: That's, in fact, what this axiom
of unitarity measuring a state leaves the
particle in the measured state means.
Ander: Right.
Chris: So, yeah, mathematically, they're
duals.
Ander: Thank you.
Chris: Okay, so let's now use this theory
that we've developed to describe the
interaction between Alice and Bob.
And let's think of a situation in which
Alice prepares a qubit that Bob then
measures, and then Bob prepares the very
same qubit, and then Alice measures it.
So Alice acts with her Hamiltonian
operator, which we'll label Ha, and Bob
acts with his Hamiltonian operator that
we label HB.
And let's say that Alice prepares the
qubit as in state up.
And Bob can then measure the qubit in
state up and say, oh, the qubit is now up.
.
And if Bob then prepares the qubit in
state down, alice can measure the qubit
in state down and say, oh, the qubit
switched from the up that I prepared to
down.
So Bob must have prepared it as down.
So what's happened here?
Alice and Bob have actually shared a bit
flip.
Alice said up and Bob said, down, and
Alice heard him say down.
So they've shared this idea of change by
interacting with each other.
Now, this works as long as they mean the
same thing by up and down.
So we've implicitly assumed, in talking
about them communicating, that they both
have this reference frame that
distinguishes up from down.
And this is actually a completely general
model of what I'll call a noiseless one
qubit channel.
Now, what does that mean?
It's noiseless because there's nothing
else in the picture, right?
There's nothing in the picture that can
jiggle the qubit when Alice and Bob aren'
't looking.
Alice and Bob are the only systems we're
talking about, and they share this qubit
and there's nothing else in the picture.
So there's no kind of third party or
environment or heat bath or anything like
that that's going to mess with the qubit
and disrupt their interaction.
So that's a noiseless channel and it's a
one qubit channel because they just have
one qubit that they're interacting with
and they're alternately preparing and
measuring its state.
Now, clearly, if they can interact using
one qubit, they can interact using any
finite number of qubits.
So here's a picture of an in qubit
channel that Alice and Bob, which here I'
've labeled A and B because I took this
figure from a paper, are sharing.
And Alice and Bob both have N operators,
one for each of the N qubits that they
share.
And they just do this prepared
measurement cycle on all N qubits.
So you can think of Alice preparing the N
qubits, bob measuring the N qubits, and
then Bob preparing and Alice measuring,
and that allows them to exchange N bit
messages.
And we can make N as large as we want.
And so they can exchange messages of
arbitrary complexity.
And if they share the meaning of up and
down, then they can exchange these
messages with no noise, so they can
communicate.
And we now have our theory of two
communicating agents that are that are
sharing arbitrary finite information.
Now, I've labeled Q one through QN in
this picture, a holographic screen.
And in fact, that's exactly what it is.
Recall from session one this slide
illustrating the holographic principle.
Shannon made this point that a bit of
information is an answer to a yes no
question.
And so we can write down a number of
possible states.
We can write down an entropy.
And the limiting case of that entropy is
the entropy of a black hole.
The densest possible encoding of
information in space or on a boundary.
And this holographic principle allows us
to see any boundary, as we discuss in
session one, as an encoding of bits.
So the previous boundary of these in
qubits, we can think of as a holographic
screen.
Now, why is that important?
It's important because it allows us to
use this idea of holography and this idea
of a fixed encoding of a message or a
fixed encoding of an observable entropy
at some density that was developed in
cosmology to talk about arbitrary quantum
communication channels.
So we can import a whole bunch of theory
that was done someplace else into quantum
information theory and see that it works
perfectly because it describes exactly
the same situation.
Now, what does this tell us?
Philosophically, it tells us that Alice
and Bob can learn about each other at
most N bits per communication cycle.
So the maximal amount of information that
they can get from an observation is the
in bits that the other one wrote on the
screen.
So this tells us something very important,
, that when an agent is looking at their
environment, which is this other agent,
Bob, the amount of information that can
be extracted from the environment is
actually proportional to the size in bits
of the boundary.
And the holographic principle just makes
that size finite in space.
And I said early on that there's no
embedding spacetime in this theory, that
Alice and Bob are not thought of as
separated in space.
But as soon as we use the holographic
principle, we can think of the boundary
between them as having a spatial
coordinate, even though they don't have a
spatial coordinate.
So we'll get back to this point in
September when we talk about theories of
emergent spacetime, but all of these
theories of emergent spacetime come back
to this idea that boundaries can have
spatial extent, even though the systems
that they separate don't have any natural
spatial description or natural spatial
degrees of freedom.
Okay, so now let's recall another picture
from session one.
We talked a little bit about Feynman's
theory of scattering and the origin of
Feynman diagrams and the idea that if
Alice prepares some system in some
initial state and then measures the state
later, if we want to calculate what the
new state is.
We have to take into account all of the
possible paths that join the initial
state that Alice prepared to the final
state that Alice measured.
So what does that mean?
I mean, here effectively, if we think of
suppose I'm Alice and the boundary is my
screen, I'm talking to the screen, and
then later on, I'm going to measure the
screen.
And between my preparation actions and my
measurement actions, a bunch of stuff
happens on the other side of the screen.
And if I want to predict what's going to
happen on the other side of the screen, I'
've got to take into account every
possible thing.
That could happen.
And I have to give some weight to those
possible things that could happen.
And Quantum theory, in fact, tells you
how to assign those weights to things
that could happen in order to make a
measurement, given some theory of the
mechanism that makes things happen.
But the fact that all of the paths have
to be counted is what unitary evolution
means.
This evolution that preserves information
that doesn't take any away, it doesn't
add any, it just represents it in
different ways.
So if you look at this screen and imagine
that Alice is interacting with her
boundary and then she's interacting with
her boundary again, it looks just like
the previous screen.
And the wavy red arrows are what's
happening inside Bob.
The wavy red arrows are a representation
of what's going on inside Bob as he
measures his side of the screen and then
prepares his side of the screen.
So what Feynman is representing here is
just the action of the environment or the
action of the system while Alice isn't
looking.
Between Alice's preparation stage and her
measurement stage, while Bob is doing his
measurement and preparation.
So this diagram is actually completely
symmetrical.
We could have drawn an arrow where the
wavy red things are and drawn wavy red
things where we talked about Alice.
And we'd have the same picture just from
Bob's point of view.
We can also think of this, of course, as
Alice communicating with her future self
by writing a memory record someplace in
the world and then coming back and
reading it.
And if Alice writes a memory on the world
and then comes back later on and reads it,
, she actually has to take into account
some theory of all of the things the
world might have done to her memory while
she wasn't looking.
So this picture of Feynman's actually
tells us a lot about memory.
And when we think about organisms running
around in the world doing things like we
do all the time, we tend to think of
memories as things that are persistent
and unchanging and all of that.
But we know that that's not true.
We know that memories degrade in various
ways.
We know that adversarial third parties
can come and change what we've done so
that they fool us into thinking that we'
've remembered something that we haven't.
.
And so on and so forth.
That whole picture of memory is actually
encoded in this picture that Feynman drew
in the late fifty S to represent
scattering of particles.
So what we've done here is started with
this simple idea of asking questions.
And we've actually constructed a fair
amount of Quantum theory.
We constructed the Schrodinger equation,
we constructed the unitary propagator.
We constructed the idea of a reference
frame, which we'll talk about intensely
next time in July.
So we can sum this up by saying that
Quantum theory simply is a theory of
communicating agents.
And that quantum mechanics, the theory
that Feynman was complaining about in
that earlier slide, that quantum
mechanics generates this problem that
seems intractable of how to understand
measurement, because the theory is in
fact about measurement.
It's not about mechanical motion at all.
So quantum theory actually tells us
nothing about ontology.
And this is why the interpretations of
quantum theory, the many worlds
interpretation, where you have all these
branching universes and so forth, are not
really science.
They're philosophy.
They're attempts to understand an
ontology that's generated by a theory
that doesn't talk about ontology.
It talks about communication between
agents.
But we've left something very important
out.
We've left out a consideration of what
happens when Alice and Bob don't mean the
same thing by up and down.
And we've left out the famous phenomenon
of entanglement spooky action at a
distance, as Einstein called it.
And it turns out these things that we've
left out are very, very closely related.
And we're going to see why in July.
But I'm going to give you a brief preview
now.
So what happens when Alice and Bob
actually mean different things by up and
down?
What if their reference frames aren't
aligned?
Well, the first thing to note is that
nothing in the theory says they have to
be aligned.
So we have to consider the possibility
that they're not.
And in fact, both Alice and Bob have to
have what's called free choice of
reference frame.
When Alice prepares her instrument, she
has to be able to prepare it any way she
wants to in order to do an experiment.
And when Bob makes up a sentence to tell
Alice, he has to be able to choose any
language he wants to use, he's a free
agent in this way.
And if they don't have that freedom, it
turns out they're entangled.
So reference frame, nonalignment and
entanglement are very, very closely
coupled.
Now, misalignment of reference frames is
what produces superpositions of outcomes.
.
So if Alice makes her measurements with
her up and down arrow arranged vertically,
, for example, but Bob prepares his qubit
with his up and down arrow arranged at 90
degrees to Alice's, alice is not going to
have any idea what Bob did.
I mean, she can't see distinctions in the
left right direction.
She can only see distinctions in the up
and down direction.
So all she can do is flip a coin.
If she wants to know what Bob prepared,
it's 50% likely he prepared up for her
what she calls one.
And it's 50% likely that he prepared what'
's down for her.
She can't tell.
Now, if Bob's reference frame is pointing
at about 45 degrees.
So up for him means 45 degrees off of
Alice's up, then she can sort of tell
what he did.
If he's pointing 45 degrees from up, then
she's probably going to measure up.
And if he's pointing 45 degrees from down,
, she's probably going to measure down.
So her outcomes are 75% for one and 25%
for minus one.
If he prepares at this 45 degree angle.
So we can write this in a particular way.
.
We can say that the value that Alice gets
acting with her M on a qubit that Bob
prepared is some number times what she
measures as up plus some other number
plus times what she measures as minus one,
, where those numbers, the squares of
those numbers, add to one.
So why do they have to add to one?
Well, they add to one because of the
Pythagorean theorem.
One is the distance, the total distance
between the two outcomes.
And A squared plus B squared are the
other two sides of that triangle.
So another way to think of it is that the
metric distance in possibility space is
one and A squared and B squared are just
the Euclidean distance components.
Again, Euclidean distance is based on the
Pythagorean theorem.
So this is the Born rule in quantum
theory.
It's the rule that tells us what happens
when we're trying to measure a
superposition and it tells us where these
superpositions come from.
We have a mismatch in reference frames
between two agents that are communicating.
.
So if we go back to the free energy
principle, which is what this whole
active inference class is about, and we
formulate it in quantum theory, we get a
very simple idea of what the free energy
principle is.
The FEP and quantum theory just says that
interacting systems are going to behave
in a way that aligns their reference
frames and that makes their communication
as good as it can be.
But since aligning reference frames
perfectly leads to entanglement, the free
energy principle drives systems
asymptotically toward entanglement.
Well, the principle of unitarity says
that all systems will approach
entanglement asymptotically.
So we can see the FEP is actually a
classical statement of the principle of
unitarity.
And what we'll see in the next session is
why this is the case, why active
inference, when we think of it, quantum
mechanically is a way of talking about
the principle of unitarity, which is the
deepest axiom of quantum theory.
And we'll also see that this question of
alignment becomes more and more complex
as the complexity of the messages that
the systems are trying to communicate to
each other increases.
And that message complexity correlates
with system complexity.
So that aligning complicated systems is
very hard, although aligning very simple
systems is fairly easy.
And if you think about what's the
simplest possible theory in science, it's
particle physics, because you're dealing
with these very simple things that
interact in extremely simple ways.
And the really difficult parts of science
are things like sociology, where you're
dealing with incredibly complicated
systems like humans that interact in
incredibly complicated ways.
And all we have are very vague kind of
folk theories of how that works.
But we know from that example that
aligning complex systems is extremely
difficult.
So humans don't get along very well.
So the second session well, the second
discussion section which Andrew will be
leading is on Saturday, the 1 July, a
couple of weeks from now.
The third lecture session will be on July
13 and I hope you all will contribute to
the interactive question and answer
session on the web and show up for the
discussion on Saturday, the 1 July and
join us again in July for the discussion
of quantum reference frames and reference
frame alignment.
So thank you very much.
Daniel: Thank you, Chris.
Ander: All right.
Daniel: Thank you all again.
Please check out the course syllabus, ask
questions through the site and see you at
the discussion.
See you next time.
Thank you.
Bye.